you find them - through contacts you
find them through your networks you find
them through references you find them to
references of your own employees who
refer very good people to us and you
make judgments right away you can use
quantitative tests and profiling tests
you use aids to your judgment but
ultimately there is no substitute to
sound management judgment and intuitive
feel whether the person is right for the
job and right for your company
you're the reality of everything is
whether it be social service whether it
be business whether it be politics is
that standards of expectations are going
up and it has to follow that
expectations from employees keep going
up there always be a certain percentage
of your population which is unable to
grow with the requirements of the
customer and what we do is we give them
performance improvement programs to be
able to upgrade them if they are still
not able to grow in requirement of what
the customers require we then out place
them but we do it in a manner which is
gentle enough and we give them enough
time to get a job and the vast vast
majority of people we out place very
often get jobs which are comparable
because you've got a strong brand is a
company
the one he must have passion he or she
must have passion to he or she must be
willing to take challenges because it is
challenges which really take the
organization to excellent
it is challenges which make ordinary
people extraordinary performers three
the person must have a social purpose in
other words he must have a approach or
she must have an approach which is
broader than the task at hand and also
keep in mind that this entity to the
environment the sensitivity to society
the sensitivity to people in the
organization and there is a requirement
of being in a position to achieve
leadership in that business and for most
important which is completely
uncompromising the person must be of
unquestionable integrity and must
consistently demonstrate and practice
that integrity without exceptions
I think it's a combination everything
can be learned it helps if you have the
basic intrinsic abilities for it and it
helps if you're a good listener and are
modest enough to listen and learn
quickly
so you admire various people for various
things you admired Gandhi for his vision
and his pioneering areas you admired a
person like Jack Wills for some of the
extraordinary initiative he launched in
General Electric and the way he drove
them relentlessly and successfully you
admire a person like Steve job which is
a unique combination of an enormous
businessman with an enormous
technologist you admire people like Bill
Gates for the way he's reconfigured his
life and devoted all his talents to
social service
I think you must have consistency of the
beliefs you have if you're putting a bet
on a business have a consistency of a
belief that you can make the business
work you cannot be making yes/no
decisions which are half-hearted you
cannot be sitting on the fence you
cannot be sitting on the wall you either
here or you're there that's important
dude as I said before invest in people
because every business which you want to
build people are basically the
foundation stone for it at three have
certain principles on which you run a
business whether it be leadership
whether it be integrity and consistently
practice those beliefs without exception